make sure you guys hit the subscribe
button if you guys are enjoying the
content that we're throwing up
and uh make sure you guys hit the like
button if you enjoy the video and yeah
let's begin what's going on guys this is
rob
and we are back with avengers and new
avengers by jonathan hickman yes we are
we are following up to that enormous
cliffhanger that i left you guys
on we're finally getting in to all the
answers that you guys
have been wanting all the answers to all
your questions so what we end up doing
here is picking up four days ago and
that's kind of the cool thing about this
this little bit of the story we kind of
go four days ago then three days ago
then two days ago and then one day ago
and so on but basically this four days
ago moment this happens essentially
immediately after hank pym tells a story
right about how like the beyonders are
there the beyonders were wiping out all
the cosmic entities and kind of says the
whole scenario is hopeless and what
they're looking for
is evidence of this right like is it
true that the living tribunal fell
at the hands of the power of the
beyonders right is this true because if
it is
then it really is just a lost cause
right and so what they end up doing is
accessing the information of tony stark
and so accessing the information in his
database if you guys recall
tony stark found out the living tribunal
had died a long time ago like we covered
that during the events of original sin
so iron man has known
longer than anybody else i need you guys
to keep that in mind
because that'll become one of the most
important elements of
everything going forward but the idea
here is that beast and
amadeus cho and hank pym basically end
up locating the corpse of the living
tribunal so it is verified the living
tribunal has been dead and then of
course you basically end up having the
incredible hulk and you have brian
braddock who are dispatched to go
investigate right to go find the corpse
of living tribunal and see what's going
on
from there we we jump forward one day we
switched to three days ago and we pick
up with nation x now a little bit of an
explanation here
we're remastering avengers and new
avengers right so this takes place
before jonathan hickman's uh jonathan
hickman's x-men run
so this takes place before everything
that's happening in x-men right now
which is why you don't see krakowa you
don't see charles xavier with his helmet
or anything like that and this all takes
place
long before that so the one that clocked
back here a little bit the way this kind
of x-men timeline works in terms of how
we got here and this is going to be kind
of a really quick rundown so those of
you guys who are familiar with the x-men
with their history up to this point
bear with me for a second for all you
new people the x-men timeline kind of
worked pretty consistently across the
board until we got to the mid to late
2000s in the sense that you had the the
xavier school for gifted youngsters out
in westchester and that's just where
they operated right they always
functioned there this changed during the
events of dark rain and dark rain was a
story
that followed the events of secret
invasion right so if you guys remember
civil war the story of civil war for
marvel comics tony stark became the new
director of shield that led to the
events of house of m and then secret
invasion and secret invasion revealed
that the skrull race had secretly been
replacing superheroes
the fact that tony stark didn't know
that was reason for him to be terminated
as the director of shield he was
replaced with norman osborne now there's
a few other reasons behind the scenes
why that happened but the overall gist
is that norman osborne the green goblin
replaced tony stark and then he
basically turned shield into like this
organization where he tried to use it to
conquer the world during that time
the x-men got while the getting was good
and so they basically left westchester
they left new york and they went off the
coast of san francisco
to a place called utopia it was a kind
of island that was granted to them
by the mayor of san francisco and it was
their own personal residence right so
they took up residence in utopia and
they'd always been there right now this
leads into two things it leads into
avengers versus x-men and it leads into
an event called schism
avengers vs x-men was as most of you
guys know the story where cyclops had
received a portion of the phoenix force
and then killed charles xavier
schism is a story that we have covered
you'll find that down in the description
but this was a story
where basically cyclops and wolverine
ended up splitting right so basically
you had wolverine who took a portion of
the mutants who were at
utopia and left and re-opened the school
in westchester and so you had two x-men
schools going on at that point in time
nation x is basically what utopia was
called that's more or less what this
is right now this goes into basically
robert decosta and uh
and sam guthrie cannonball basically
approaching cyclops and saying hey man
so like it's time for us to start
getting involved and cyclops's response
is yeah i mean here at the end of days
it's time for us to get involved in this
whole thing right the days of the x-men
sitting idly by
and not really getting involved those
are over because what cyclops says
is what's going on out there is much
bigger than like the avengers or the
fantastic four like we're looking at the
end of times and if we are looking at
the end of times then the name of the
game is not
saving what we have the name of the game
is resurrection and what better force
out there
embodies resurrection than the phoenix
and that's what we basically end up
learning that cyclops
has a phoenix egg the phoenix force will
be reborn and cyclops intends to take
possession of the phoenix force in its
entirety now from here
we switched to two days ago and we have
this kind of discussion there was a
point where valeria had slipped reed
richards a note through susan storm that
said
you can't win time to find a way to not
lose and that's what reed richards had
basically figured out what reed richards
has done here is basically create a raft
right and he gives a credit he's talking
to black panther he gives a credit to
valeria and says like basically she's
the one that kind of gave me the idea
for this but that's when valeria chimes
in and says yes you've answered one
question but as with so many things when
one question is answered another
question gets asked and so now the
question you have to ask yourself is
now that you have a means to escape the
world who gets to go it's a limited
capacity only so many people get to go
that's one of the reasons why
reed richards is really one of the only
people who could make this choice if it
were left to black panther he'd probably
choose his own people
but reed is the one who makes the choice
really kind of comes to the decision and
he says
what we need here are individuals who
are multi-disciplined what's better to
have
on a life raft a person who's skilled in
in
multiple forms of medicine as well as
building things or a person
who's only good at building things an
engineer or a person who's an engineer
and a doctor what's the best scenario to
have there and the response is a
multi-faceted person right a
multi-disciplined candidate they should
take priority over highly specialized
ones now notice they're not talking
about average joes here right they're
not talking about regular individuals in
reality there's no room for that there's
no room to scoop up as many people from
new york as you can they're gone there's
nothing you can do for them right
they're just gonna die and that's just
the way it is and it sucks to be them
that's just how it goes sometimes and so
the only real way is to kind of focus on
saving as many multi-disciplined people
as you can
those individuals who can help rebuild
and then later see if you can't find a
way to bring
different people back and so that's when
we get into the real kind of kicker in
this little bit of the video is we
switch over to one day ago and you've
got sam guthrie you've got
a super guardian if you guys remember
her like in the early days of hickman's
run she was the first human to ever
ever be brought into the shiar imperial
guard and of course you've got robert de
costa right they're all just kind of
talking to each other spend spending
time together and so on and then super
guardian is basically called away and
she's she's basically called by
by gladiator right now remember
gladiator is the leader of the shiar
empire but at one point he was the
person who was the leader of the
imperial guard and the idea behind this
is that he immediately kind of prefaces
what it is he's getting ready to say by
telling her
i once served as the leader of the
imperial guard right i led the forces of
the shiar empire against multiple
threats both foreign and domestic and i
understand the sacrifice that we
as the as the imperial guard make in the
name of our duty but the reality is that
being part of the imperial guard means
you serve the imperial guard first and
then you serve whoever your loyalties
are to
second and that's when he says i'm
recalling you i'm bringing you back into
service of the shia
empire bring your family you know bring
whoever it is that you need you're
reporting here and her immediate
response is like
no i mean i've i need like i need time
to be able to leave and he's like no
like you've got
minutes you know and it's kind of like
okay but like it's a long distance to
get there like i have to get them ready
and his response is we're not
nearly as far away from you as you think
we are switch over to the outer solar
system so basically they're on the edge
of the solar system of of the sol system
so they're out by like pluto basically
and you end up having gladiator talking
to
oracle now oracle is both the kind of
telepath of sorts or really just a
straight telepath for the shiar empire
but she's also one of the closest
confidants of of gladiator alongside
mentor who's this other confidant right
so they're basically his closest
advisors and oracle's really kind of
taking
a reasonable approach here and saying
look like humanity has saved us right
humanity saved us during the events
of infinity right they they're the ones
who pulled out all the stops thor of
earth is the one who basically showed
that we could destroy a builder and
because of captain america's and you
know
his quick thinking and his knowledge in
battle strategy we came out on top we're
honor bound to them we're honor bound to
humanity we can't just
blow up their world this is a sneak
attack is what this is like literally
we're mustering forces we're sneaking to
their planet and then we're going to
annihilate it we can't do that to them
and the responsive gladiator is
that's a fair argument to make and so
then he in turn turns to mentor right
and he tells mentor oracle is besieging
the honor of the shiar empire and this
is not something that falls on deaf ears
i am an
honorable man and i understand the value
of honor present your case to me and i
will make my decision accordingly and in
turn mentor basically says
the first thing that needs to be said
here is the reason why we're approaching
earth at the 11th hour is because i
screwed up
i should have seen the signs before and
had i seen the signs before we could
have been a help in evacuation
and helping them leave their world or
possibly even combining our technology
for the purpose of finding a solution to
all this
such as it is i didn't see the signs
until it was too late and the only
option we have now is to destroy their
world that's the only option we have if
we destroy earth we save the universe
and the response of gladiator you know
when you end up having oracle saying
this kind of blind nobility and all that
kind of stuff it doesn't do anything it
doesn't serve any real purpose
gladiator you're an honorable man you
have to be honor bound here and
gladiator makes the tough choice here
right heavy is the head that wears the
crown
his response is yes it is an honorable
thing to spare earth it's an honorable
thing to warn the superheroes who are
there
we're coming get off your world as fast
as you can we're going to destroy it but
at the end of the day i
am not the leader of the imperial guard
i am not the leader of a fighting force
my loyalty is to the empire and my job
is to do whatever i need to do
to spare the empire and if the continued
survival of earth means
a continued threat to the universe and
by extension a continued threat to my
people then i will destroy the earth if
i have to
and that's where we are now you
basically end up having revealed that
what's happened here is is gladiator has
called together the entire armada right
all the fighting forces of the cree
the shia the scrolls the badoon the
brood basically the universe
has cited against earth but do not fret
rob core do not fret rob core i know
right now you guys are probably looking
down to see how much time we have left
in this video
with that being said guys we're going to
bring this video to you now i'm not
going to do that to you guys
do not fret because there is a saving
grace this saving grace comes in the
form of a small little ship which is
out there with the rest of the big ships
and they're just kind of coasting along
and they're trying to find some way to
hack into the imperial
battle net that's being shared by all
these different races this group of
course is none other than the guardians
of the galaxy
yes the saving grace of humanity comes
in a ragtag group of people who were led
by what may very well be one of the most
inept people in the history of the
universe so uh you basically end up
having rocket raccoon who like hacks
into the into the battle net and comes
to the realization this is really just a
sneak attack right because the reason
they're here was to ask the question
like
why are all the various forces coming
together right like why are all these
empires
binding together like surely there's
some major threat out there what in the
heck did this threat possibly be and we
are the guardians of the galaxy right
our job is to protect the galaxy as best
we can
and so that's when they basically
realize this entire armada has a symbol
to destroy the world like that's nuts
and when you when you have like gamora
and you've got a peter quill and they're
like okay well we kind of have to warn
the earth the response of rocket raccoon
is
why would we do that why would we warn
the earth like the earth is a pain
let them die right he's like the only
people like do you know what people
do like the kind of people who go
running towards you know
a major conflict like this who would
like go to earth and warn the
superheroes their idiots are the kind of
people who would do that switch forward
and you've got rocket raccoon talking to
all these various superheroes on earth
right you got reed richards the
fantastic four you've got captain
america you basically have like you know
the illuminati the avengers and the new
avengers all assembled together and and
their whole response is
no we're not going to evacuate our world
we're going to try to find a way to stay
and we're going to go down with the ship
if we can and it's like you guys are
total idiots
right like you guys are total idiots for
doing that now at this point we switch
over
to the nature of raboom allah yes we
finally
get the identity of raboom allah the
person who is the origin of the
incursions the reason
why all this is happening in the first
place so we end up switching to this
alternate earth right and we have the
black priests of doctor strange that are
led by steven strange who are now
observing what is basically this doorway
now if you guys recall
in the early days of hickman's avengers
and new avengers we talked about the
origin of black swan and we talked about
the doors to the library the library of
worlds and one of the things that
hickman explained here is that what you
had
is you had the black swans who were part
of kind of like or they were basically a
religious cult that served or boom along
and that boom all resided inside the
library of worlds essentially and that
this library of worlds was originally a
gift from the ivory kings right it was
originally there it was originally
created by the beyonders and somewhere
along the line it was co-opted by rabu
mall right he basically took it over and
took it for himself and then all the
black swans are now there and the idea
is that there's different doorways to
access this
uh this this library they exist on
different worlds the problem that that
doctor strange and the the black priests
have is that up to this point
all the worlds they'd catalogued that
had doorways to the library of world had
all been destroyed in the incursions and
so they finally found one right they
finally found one that had not been
destroyed but the issue is that the
incursion is getting ready to happen
here right this incursion is going to be
happening within you know what well it's
kind of referred to as like less than
one unit of standard celestial time who
knows what that means right we'll just
say like an hour
right and so because of that it's kind
of like okay then like we kind of have
to get in here right we have to
basically get to this doorway
and then access the library and so what
it does is it leads to
all the forces of the black priest
descending onto these three black swans
and attacking the issue with this
is that one of the black swans manages
to get to the doorway and then shuts it
while the rest are destroyed and so what
happens of course
because they have a key they're able to
access the door after destroying the
last of the black swans and then they
enter and so of course doctor strange
uses his magic to basically
find where it is this black swan had ran
to in order to essentially follow the
trail and we end up going through like
these
these really interesting places right i
mean this library is not a library in
the traditional sense it's a library
insofar
as it's a place that holds vast amounts
of knowledge but the form in which this
knowledge takes
shifts from one room to the next and so
in one room you have like this wall of
individuals who have all housed over the
course of their lives or attained some
wildly interesting forms of knowledge
right like magical artifacts or
different kinds of spells or different
things like that
and so one of these people i don't know
if you guys notice but one of these guys
is thanos it's the face of thanos right
which is probably just like an alternate
reality where thanos became like the
sorcerer supreme or something along
those lines we're not really giving any
information but you also have kind of
like these glowing orbs that are
basically repositories of information
that are composed entirely of light and
that's kind of how this is but
eventually they get to a point whereby
as soon as they try to speak nothing
happens and the way this works is this
is what's called
a quiet room right this is basically a
room where there are no words and this
is what's kind of crazy here because
this is the room where the black swans
launch their attack against the black
priest because remember the black
priests
have to use words in order to pull off
their spells and what is a black priest
who can't speak it's a powerless
individual and so because of that
the attack is launched by all the black
swans and they immediately start wiping
out
all the black priests but despite the
black priest's limitations remember
steven strange is the sorcerer supreme
and while he knows all
the different spells of the black priest
steven strange doesn't need to speak
to cast his spells and so because of
that the issue of steven strange here
isn't so much his inability to cast a
spell it's the fact that he's dealing
with so many black swans who have such
incredible power at their disposal and
so what this leads to
is steven strange casting these massive
spells doing all kinds of of
wildly you know capable abilities but
the issue with this is that ultimately
it ends up seeing the fall of steven
strange right see stephen strange
completely overpowered by all these
black swans the result is that he
subdued
and taking him to the center of the
library right to the center of the
library of worlds and basically say like
we're going to present you with the root
with reboom along and when they say like
you know they basically tell them like
this is the furthest we can go they drop
them off and they leave the explanation
that's given here
is that there are no black swans who
know who abu mal looks like they don't
know what he looks like
and the idea is that any any black swan
who looks upon
reboom allah will basically go blind
right and the only individuals that
serve in his direct
you know direct vicinity are two old
blind women right that's that's the only
thing like literally they gouge their
eyes out so they could never actually
look upon who
boom allah is and so the reality is that
whoever this guy is he wants to keep his
identity secret and there's good reason
for that and this
comes when he finally reveals himself
when stephen strange is standing before
this pantheon and the doorway
opens and the old blind woman can't see
him smoke
fills the room and he simply says enter
and the response of
all is in all the worlds in all the
universes i would never
have expected to see you despite the
fact that the only reason stephen
strange is alive
is because he caught the interests of
raboom allah that's the only reason why
he wasn't killed by the black swans is
because he caught the interest of
verbuma law and he instructed the black
swans to bring him here as opposed to
just killing him where he stood in the
quiet room
and rabumi law finally reveals his
identity and it's doctor doom
now this is the question that has to be
asked this is the question
that you guys are undoubtedly going to
ask because this is this is
literally dr strahan i'm sorry dr doom
who was working with the molecule man
the molecule man owen reese is there
and the the response of dr dr strange is
what in the heck is going like
how are you here right like your reboom
allah and the response to doctor doom is
yes right i've built a religion and it
has stoked a grand fire within me
i'm the one who created the black swans
now here's the question that we kind of
have to ask here
if doctor doom is the person who started
the incursions
then why is it that dr doom was looking
for the source of the incursions
how does this work well he knows he's
the one that created the incursions he
knows that he is
and we'll find out why he knows that he
is in the next video with that being
said guys we're gonna bring this to an
end yes we're gonna bring this video
to an end the cliffhangers are real we
will find out
all the answers in the next video i
promise
i promise i promise i promise we will
find out all the answers in the next
video the origin of the incursions the
whole nine yards what dr doom's been
doing
how the incursions got started look at
the answers to all that stuff with that
being said guys we're gonna bring this
to an end
if you are new here to comments
explained make sure you guys hit the sub
button to become part of the rob core if
you guys enjoyed this video make sure
you drop a like
and i will catch you all later peace
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
you